All right, Data2100 students, let's
jump into our introduction to databases.
So our objectives for today, number
one, we're going to focus on why
do databases exist? Why do we even
need them? Why do we even care?
Then we're going to look at
understanding the structure
of a single table and
database and then identifying
different components of
a relational database.
So how do we store data? Let's think
about this. How do we store data?
and you're like well you know I
store data like I'm storing images
on my phone right okay yeah images
are absolutely data maybe you're
storing data maybe you're throwing
all of your documents into a google
drive maybe you're storing data
in excel spreadsheets right maybe
you're really getting into excel
spreadsheets I love excel it can
be really really powerful so maybe
those are some personal ways that
you're storing data you know all
of your text messages and things
are stored on your phone. Your
phone is probably storing a ton of
your data, and your phone is probably
backing up to the cloud, which
is storing your data there. So we
store data in a lot of different
ways, but how do we store data that
sits in our rows and columns, like
an Excel spreadsheet? How do we
store that type of data? How do we
store data that is tracking all of
our transactions that are happening
at the local convenience store.
How is that data being stored?
So one thing to consider is when
we've been dealing with Excel
spreadsheets in this class, they are
very powerful, right? But there are
a couple of problems with spreadsheets.
They are not meant for long
-term data storage. If you have tons
of data in an Excel spreadsheet,
you have millions of records of
rows, you are going to expect
data loss and slow load time. So
when you try and open up that Excel
spreadsheet with millions of records
of data, you are going to have
more than likely slow load
time. And at times when
you open up a really large
Excel spreadsheet, it will
say potential data loss
and throw an error code.
Just so you're aware of that. So
we don't store data long-term in
Excel spreadsheets. Now, especially
as companies are getting started
and they're working with their
data and things like that, that's
probably where they're going to
start. But we want to always maneuver
over into a database that is going
to have our long-term storage of
our data. So again, we're talking
about data that fits in rows and
columns. So when we look at, oh, I
meant rows and columns. I don't know
if you saw my hand down here,
but I did the opposite way. My
apologies. So security issues are
another problem with spreadsheets. Data
sharing, unintentional delete and
update errors. So there's a lot
of issues with spreadsheets, right?
And we use Excel with spreadsheets,
but there's also different types
of tools that use spreadsheets.
So this is when databases come
into play. This is how we can
preserve data quality and store
data long-term in databases.
All right, so there's data everywhere,
right? We in this class are
going to be focusing on structured
data. So structured data is again
that data that can fit in rows and
columns. So these are data that
fit into rows and columns, can be
stored in relational databases like
we're going to be working on in this
class. These are numbers, dates,
and strings and it comprises a
lot of data stored in this world.
However, so we're going to be
focusing on structured data.
Unstructured data is things that
cannot be displayed in rows,
columns, and relational databases.
So images, audio file, emails,
things like that. Those are
things that are not going to be
stored in rows and columns,
especially looking at images, audio,
and video, right? That is still
data, but it's not necessarily
going to fit neatly as is into
a rows and columns type of
data. So we're going to focus
on rows and columns, looking at,
think of transactions. That's
going to a lot of our examples
in this class is transaction
data, right? That you went to
the store this morning, went
to a convenience store, you got
yourself, I don't know, a Diet
Coke or you got yourself a candy
bar, whatever it may be. That
transaction is being tracked
somewhere and it's going to be
as in somewhere in a database.
So how many of you have used
a database? I kind of gave
away my answer just, just barely.
When I asked this class to
my 250 students in person,
many of them, like maybe one or
two of them raised their
hand, but really all of them
should raise their hand because
we have all used a database.
Whether or not we knew it
or not, that's the thing
is we might not raise our
hand because we're like,
well, I've never interacted
seemingly directly
with a database, but you have.
If you've ever made an
Amazon purchase, if you've
ever made any sort of
type of purchase, you are
going to be interacting
with some sort of database.
It's just not directly, not
what you're seeing. You're
just looking at, you know,
I'm giving you $20 for this
transaction at the local
convenience store. But that
transaction is being tracked
somewhere into a database.
So at any time that you're doing
any sort of Google query or you're
interacting on the web or you've
liked something on Instagram, those
things are all being tracked on the
back end by a database so just keep
that in mind that even though maybe
you haven't worked with one directly
we use them all of the time and
they fuel so much of what we do all
right so databases are homes for data
this is a place where data can be
securely stored and retrieved in an
organized matter this is how we maintain
data quality and organization
there's lots of different types of
databases. There's relational databases.
There's hierarchical databases.
There's so many different
types of databases. In this
class, we're going to be focusing
in on relational databases.
This is the type of database
that we'll focus on.
So this is a great question. Why
should I care about databases?
Number one, they are
everywhere. They enable business
operations. They are the backbone
of virtually every single
transactional software system.
They enable business analytics.
They hold data that enables
executives, managers, and other
stakeholders to make better
decisions. So if you're going into
business, you are going to have
interactions with databases.
In your daily life, you have
interactions with databases as
a consumer. and some of you may
be interacting with them more
directly rather than just on
a transactional type of basis.
But as you continue into your
education, as you're working,
you will have a ton of interaction
with databases. You might
just not think of them as
databases, right? As you're working
with software, as you're doing
things like that, you are still
going to be working with that
data is being stored somewhere.
So a database administrator
versus a data analyst. I want to
kind of understand the distinction
here. So there is a whole
field of study about database
administration, and that's a
whole career. So this is the
person who manages the database.
They understand the data needs of
the organization and set up the
database to be able to fit into those
needs. Again, multiple databases.
They architect, develop, maintain
those databases. they assign who
has access to what so that's gonna
be the person who manages the
database in our class we're gonna
focus more on being a data analyst
so this is a person who uses debate
the database to gain business
insight okay so these are the
people that are going to identify
the business problem that needs
to be addressed and then gather
data from the database to answer
a business question all right so
we're gonna focus in in on more
on being consumers of data rather
than administering a database,
okay? So I just want you to keep
that in mind. But when we're
consuming data, we need to pull data
from a database, which is what
we're going to start out with here.
All right,
so whoa, let's slow down just
for a minute. Let's go through
a few more definitions and
examples. So databases are homes
for data, but what exactly does
that mean. So when we're talking
specifically about relational
databases, this is a set of
related tables which are organized
by rows and columns, okay?
Relational databases were actually
invented in 1970 by EF Codd of IBM.
Still, they are the standard
for storing organizational
data today. So there's relational
databases still reign in
enterprises. No SQL keeps
rising, but relational databases
still dominate big data.
Relational still matters. The
amount of databases that is
relational versus other things.
There's so many relational
databases are still used all the
time. So we're going to start out
there with relational databases.
It's going to give you a good
foundation as we are talking
about being consumers of data in
this data and information class.
All right, so a database management
system, this is a software
application that allows users to
create, read, update, and delete data in
a relational database. So this
basically is the system that we're
going to be, that we're going to be
semi-interacting with that allow,
that basically is allowing us to
create, update, and delete data in our
database. So we as the users are
going to be here communicating with
our database management system and
in turn it's going to be working
with our database. So the database
management system, if you will,
is going to be helping us manage
that database. So we're going
to be utilizing a database
management system. Again, it's a
software application that allows
us to create, read. This means
like gather the data. When we
say read, we're going to be, when
we're reading data, we're going
to be gathering that data from
the database, update and delete
data in our relational database.
So there's two different types
of database management systems,
kind of two different, not types,
I should say, two different
umbrella terms. There's an
enterprise database management
system, and there's a personal
database management system.
So when we think about
enterprise database management
systems, some of you may have
heard of Oracle or Microsoft SQL
server, MySQL, there's lots
of them. These are large
organizational and work group
databases. These have thousands
of users. There's many
different database applications.
Here's just some examples. A
personal database example is
like Microsoft Access. This
comes as part of Microsoft 365
or like with your Excel type
of download, if you will.
It's a Microsoft product. It's
a smaller, simpler application,
and it's mainly for smaller
or personal applications.
All right, so in this class, we
are going to be using Microsoft SQL
Server, and I'll talk more about that
as we get into actually accessing
our relational database. So
let's look at the anatomy of a
relational database. We know why they
exist, right, to help us store data,
maintain data quality and be able
to fuel business insights, right?
That's where we're going to consume
our data. They also help fuel,
this is something we'll learn further
in the class, they help us fuel
into our data warehouse, into our
really long-term storage of data.
So let's start though with an
anatomy of our relational database.
So here is the format of a single
table in a database. So this is one
table in a database. You might be
looking at this and being like, Reagan,
this kind of looks like an Excel
spreadsheet. And you're right in
terms of there's rows and there's
columns, okay? So let's take a look at
this. So here I have a row, right?
This is all about Sam Jones, okay?
So Sam Jones, I know that Sam's
first name is, well, yeah, the first
name here is Sam, the last name
here is Jones, and then I have this
customer ID field. This is my primary
key, okay? So my primary key is a
customer ID. This is how I uniquely
identify Sam Jones as a customer
in my database here, in
my database table. So
customer ID is uniquely
identifying Sam Jones.
These primary keys are
unique. They do not repeat.
Oftentimes they're all numeric.
Sometimes they're alphanumeric, meaning
they have letters and numbers, but
they are unique. That is the most
important thing to remember about
a primary key is they are unique. I
want you to think about what is
something that uniquely identifies you?
right so i want to think you to
think of what are some things that
may be your unique identifier
whether that's at school, whether
that's maybe you have a unique ID
on one of your gaming platforms,
whether it's a unique ID at work,
whatever it may be. So let's think
about unique IDs. So you as a
student at Utah State University
through concurrent enrollment, you as
that student, you have an A number.
An A number uniquely identifies
you. I have an A number, you have
an A number, we have an A number.
And that A number says that you
are, in this case, it'd be, you
know, number one, Sam Jones. And we
can uniquely identify with your
A number the classes that you've
taken, through which campuses you're
taking the classes, are you taking
them via concurrent enrollment,
what grades did you receive in
the class, what tuition do you owe,
all those types of things. They
help us uniquely identify you as a
student at Utah State University.
So primary keys are so important
in a relational database. In this
table here, we have one primary
key, right? This is uniquely
identifying this whole record
here. So Sam Jones number one. If I
know customer ID number one, I can
figure out that they are Sam Jones
and this is their phone number,
okay? So these are all of the
columns, fields, attributes, and
variables. So these are all my
columns here, right? Customer ID
is a column, first name, last name,
and phone number is a column.
Customer ID is also a primary key.
What we're going to,
though, call these is
we're going to be calling
these field names.
And we can also call them
headers, if you will.
So these might be called here
field names or column headers.
Then we have our records,
which we can see here. We
have Nicole Sam down here
has a customer ID of seven.
Nicole, Sam, and their phone number.
All right,
so relational database tables.
Let's go into even more detail with them.
So relational database consists of a
set of tables just like we looked at.
Each table stores information about
one entity or thing of interest.
So in this back example, this
one is all about our customers.
This example, this is all about
friends, okay? So we have a
table named friend. This stores
information about our friends.
These consist of again, rows and
columns, and then primary and
foreign keys. So here, if I take
a look at this friend table,
I have my column headings here,
my field headings, if you will.
And I can see here that
I have a friend ID,
first name, last name,
phone, and city. So I
am tracking that
information about my friends
in this database table. So
which of these field headings
here, or column headings, are
uniquely identifying my friends?
Which one is uniquely
identifying it, meaning it cannot
repeat? I hope you say it's
friend ID here. Yep, you're right.
Okay, friend ID 1, 2, 3, 4,
5. That is friend ID 1, 2, 3.
These are all uniquely
identifying my friends.
Okay, perfect.
Let's keep going here. So this
primary key, again, is a column
or fill that uniquely identifies
each record. The primary
key values must be unique. They
cannot be duplicated for two
or more records. They can't.
Okay. So let's take a look at a
simple example here. All right.
So I spent a lot of time at
the dog park, and I made this
little dog park database about
dogs and the dog owners I met at
the dog park. I know. I know. I
love things like this. I love
databases. I hope that you can see the
value of them as we continue to
work with them. So here I have
my single table example of a dog
park database. So here's my dog
table, okay? I have dog ID, dog
name, dog type, and owner ID. So this
is one table in my relational
database, my dog park relational
database. One table. Now I have
dog ID, dog name, dog type, owner
ID. From this, what do you think
is my primary key of my dog table?
I hope you say, Reagan, it's dog
ID. This is uniquely identifying
number one, Molly, number two,
Mitzi, number three, Toby, and
on down. Okay. And you're
absolutely right. Dog ID here is my
primary key. Now you may be looking
though, this owner ID is unique,
right? It has ID at the end. So
that's a little bit confusing,
but it doesn't really go along
with the theme of dog table. It's
like owner ID. It kind of seems
like it's a little bit off as far
as why is it in this dog table.
So let's keep looking at this.
So now I'm going to tell you I
actually have another table in my
dog park database called the dog
owner table. I have the owner
ID, the owner name, and the owner
phone number. So I am tracking
here the owner ID, their name,
and their phone number so I can
get a hold of different owners.
All right. So which one, which one
of these columns here is the
primary key in my dog owner table?
I hope you said owner ID, right?
Owner ID is absolutely the primary
key in my dog owner table. All
right. So we have primary key
here, dog owner table. Now, as we
continue through, um, this owner
name and owner phone number,
those are still data points I'm
tracking, but owner ID is going
to be my primary key. All right.
So now I have my two tables here. They
are both a part of my
relational database.
Now I told you that a relational
database consists of related tables.
And you're probably looking at
these two going, well, there's some
sort of relationship here because
they're in a relational database
together. So let's look at this
relationship here. Okay, so let's
take a look. So dog ID is the primary
key of the dog table. We talked
about that. Owner ID is the
primary key of the dog owner table.
But what I notice here is that owner
ID is coming into my dog table.
Okay, it's coming into my dog table.
And when it does that, this
becomes the foreign key in
the dog table. So that's how
these two tables relate to
one another is this owner
ID comes over into my dog
table as the foreign key.
Okay, we abbreviate that as FK.
And the foreign key creates this
relationship between these two
tables. So I can tell, hey, when
I look at this, I can see here
that Mitzi and Toby are owned
by the same owner ID. Now, let's
just say I don't have access to
the dog owner table, but I do
know that they're both owned by
the same owner number two, right?
But when I take a look at the
dog owner table, I come over here
and I say, okay, let's take a
look at owner ID number two. Oh,
Sam's owner, here's Sam's phone
number. So the data between the two of
them relates, right? But remember
one table, my dog table only has one
theme of data, right? I only care
about one thing here. Those are my
dogs. The dog owner table, I'm only
caring about one thing there and that's
my dog owners but these two tables
do relate to one another so we use
these primary foreign key relationships
to create that relationship
okay so foreign key is a column or
field remember those columns and fields
these are what my vertical if you
will um they are interchangeable in
terms of we could say column or or
field whose values have matching
tables in the primary key of another
table, okay? So a foreign key, again,
is a column or field whose values
have matching values in the primary
key of another table, which is true,
right? My owner ID, foreign key,
column right here, is coming
from the dog owner table
as the primary key of the
dog owner table, okay?
All right, so, but why do we relate
the two tables? Why does it matter?
So number one, to avoid unintended
consequences. So updating one
record of data, but not the other.
Reduce the amount of needed storage.
Storing lots of data can
be expensive. And security,
access to some data, not
access to all. So if we didn't
relate tables, all information
for the owners would be
repeated for each dog. So this
is instead what my massive,
now I say massive here,
it's five records of data.
But let's think about this on
a way bigger scale. This is a
small example, but on a much
bigger scale, this still applies,
right? So if I was to combine
all of this data into one table,
then here when I'm looking at
Molly, an Aussie doodle, owner ID
number one, Reagan, okay, that's
one record of data here. If I was
to, again, not separate these two
tables into two separate ones,
but just combine them into one
table. However, though, when I look
at, say, Mitzi and Toby, since they
both have the same owner of Sam,
I am repeating Sam's information
twice, right? I'm repeating
Sam's information twice, their owner
name and their owner phone number.
I'm repeating that two times
because Sam owns two dogs in this
table, right? Same thing here with
Beth. So I am starting to repeat
data that I don't necessarily
need to repeat, right? Over here,
Sam and Beth are only, there's only
one time I'm tracking Sam and Beth's
name and phone number when I separate
the two tables out. However, if
I'm not to separate the two tables,
but instead keep them all as one
table, then I'm starting to repeat the
data and it's not necessary, right?
I don't need to repeat Sam twice.
I can just separate owners from
dogs and have them relate to one
another so that I'm not repeating data.
because when I go in and say I do
need to update Sam's phone number,
what if I accidentally update this
phone number but not this one, right?
Then I have a data quality issue.
So instead, when I separate
the two tables out, I only need
to change Sam's phone number one
place, okay? Now, again, looking
at five records of data, you're
like, Reagan, it's not a big
deal with five records of data.
But what about five
million records of data?
So it starts to become,
when we think about this as
data scales, and there's so
much data being collected
every minute, data is
scaling all of the time.
Therefore, when we're repeating data
that we don't need to be repeating,
then we can have unintended
consequences, we're
storing data we don't
need to, things like that.
Okay, when we're thinking about
two tables in one database,
it doesn't seem too overwhelming,
right? Okay, the two tables relate.
But what about, again, as we get more
and more and more and more tables
in a database, how can we show what
tables relate to what tables? So
the one way we can do that is by
showing a database schema. This is a
diagram that shows a structure of
the database. The most common type of
a database schema is an entity
relationship diagram. Now, if you
remember, an entity is one thing of
interest, right? So in this case we
care about the dog and the dog owner
okay so in an entity relationship
diagram this dog over here is
absolutely representing one table in my
relation in my database but it's
also one entity we can also just call
it an entity so I want you to keep
that in mind so table and entity. So
we call it an entity relationship
diagram. How do my entities or my
tables relate to one another? So
here with my dog table, my dog owner
table, I can see here that my dog
owner table relates to my dog table,
right? There's a relationship there.
So I can see that through that line,
right? And then I can see I have
this tiny little thing down here
called a crow's foot notation. A crow's
foot notation represents relationships
between tables. This side right
here is the many, many, M-A-N-Y,
right, many side. The many side
receives the foreign key to create the
relationship. The many side means
that a dog owner in this database,
a dog owner can have many dogs, right?
Which is true. Sam and Beth both
have many dogs in the database,
right? So this is saying that a dog
owner can have many dogs, but a dog
can only have one owner, okay? So
let's look at this one more time. So
a dog owner, when I read this, I'm
reading it from the dog owner table
to the dog table. A dog owner can
have many dogs, because the many
side is attached to the dog table.
When I read the other way, a dog,
and I read it as the attached here
symbol, can have one owner. Not many
owners, right? Just this one, there's
just one line here, so one owner,
okay? So a dog can have one owner.
All right now there's different
so that's how I show the
relationships and you can see here
I'm starting to interpret that
relationship right in this case
is the one to many relationship. A
dog can have one dog owner and
a dog owner can have many dogs.
All right so at this point
I want to pause the video
and we'll go on to the
next one and we're going
to talk about the types
of database relationships.